To predict the outcomes
of the Supreme Court,
Martin used cases from
1994 through 2001.
He chose this period of time
because the Supreme Court
was composed of the
same nine justices that
were justices when he made
his predictions in 2002.
These nine justices were Breyer,
Ginsburg, Kennedy, O'Connor,
Rehnquist-- who was the Chief
Justice-- Scalia, Souter,
Stevens, and Thomas.
This was a very rare data set,
since as we mentioned earlier,
this was the longest
period of time
with the same set of
justices in over 180 years.
This allowed Martin to
use a larger data set
then might have
been available if he
was doing this experiment
at a different time.
In this lecture, we'll
focus on predicting
Justice Stevens' decisions.
He is generally
considered a justice
who started out
moderate, but became
more liberal during his
time on the Supreme Court--
although, he's a
self-proclaimed conservative.
In this problem, our
dependent variable
is whether or not
Justice Stevens
voted to reverse the
lower court decision.
This is a binary variable taking
value 1 if Justice Stevens
decided to reverse or overturn
the lower court decision,
and taking value 0 if
Justice Stevens voted
to affirm or maintain
the lower court decision.
Our independent variables
are six different properties
of the case.
The circuit court of
origin is the circuit
or lower court where
the case came from.
There are 13 different circuit
courts in the United States.
The 1st through
11th and Washington,
DC courts are defined by region.
And the federal court is
defined by the subject
matter of the case.
The issue area of the
case gives each case
a category, like civil
rights or federal taxation.
The type of petitioner
and type of respondent
define two parties in the case.
Some examples are the
United States, an employer,
or an employee.
The ideological direction
of the lower court decision
describes whether
the lower court
made what was
considered a liberal
or a conservative decision.
The last variable
indicates whether or not
the petitioner argued
that a law or practice was
unconstitutional.
To collect this data,
Martin and his colleagues
read through all of the cases
and coded the information.
Some of it, like the circuit
court, is straightforward.
But other information
required a judgment call,
like the ideological
direction of the lower court.
Now that we have our
data and variables,
we are ready to predict the
decisions of Justice Stevens.
We can use logistic regression.
And we get a model where some of
the most significant variables
are whether or not the case
is from the 2nd circuit court,
with a coefficient of 1.66.
Whether or not the case is
from the 4th circuit court,
with a coefficient of 2.82.
And whether or not the
lower court decision
was liberal, with a
coefficient of negative 1.22.
Well this tells us
that the case being
from the 2nd or
4th circuit courts
is predictive of Justice
Stevens reversing the case.
And the lower court
decision being liberal
is predictive of Justice
Stevens affirming the case.
It's difficult to
understand which factors
are more important due
to things like the scales
of the variables,
and the possibility
of multicollinearity.
It's also difficult
to quickly evaluate
what the prediction
would be for a new case.
So instead of
logistic regression,
Martin and his
colleagues used a method
called classification and
regression trees, or CART.
This method builds
what is called a tree
by splitting on the values
of the independent variables.
To predict the outcome for
a new observation or case,
you can follow the splits
in the tree and at the end,
you predict the most
frequent outcome
in the training set that
followed the same path.
Some advantages of CART
are that it does not
assume a linear model,
like logistic regression
or linear regression, and it's
a very interpretable model.
Let's look at an example.
This plot shows sample data for
two independent variables, x
and y, and each data
point is colored
by the outcome
variable, red or gray.
CART tries to split
this data into subsets
so that each subset is as pure
or homogeneous as possible.
The first three splits that CART
would create are shown here.
Then the standard prediction
made by a CART model
is just the majority
in each subset.
If a new observation fell into
one of these two subsets, then
we would predict red,
since the majority
of the observations in
those subsets are red.
However, if a new
observation fell
into one of these
two subsets, we
would predict gray, since the
majority of the observations
in those two subsets are gray.
A current model is represented
by what we call a tree.
The tree for the splits
we just generated
is shown on the right.
The first split tests whether
the variable x is less than 60.
If yes, the model says to
predict red, and if no,
the model moves on
to the next split.
Then, the second split
checks whether or not
the variable y is less than 20.
If no, the model
says to predict gray,
but if yes, the model
moves on to the next split.
The third split
checks whether or not
the variable x is less than 85.
If yes, then the model says
to predict red, and if no,
the model says to predict gray.
There are a couple
things to keep
in mind when reading trees.
In this tree, and for the
trees we'll generate in R,
a yes response is always to
the left and a no response
is always to the right.
Also, make sure you always
start at the top of the tree.
The x less than 85
split only counts
for observations for
which x is greater than 60
and y is less than 20.
In the next video,
we'll discuss how
CART decides how many
splits to generate
and how the final
predictions are made.